all right wow that's me uh hello
everybody I am indeed Zach I am the
co-founder of cordin AE and I'm going to
share with you a little bit about uh
what it is how it works and why it's
useful for onchain uh online communities
to collaborate so a little bit about my
background um I spent 10 years uh as the
co-founder of converge and converge is a
consultancy that helped to launch social
and environmental impact networks all
over the world so I spent the last 10
years really steeped in both Theory and
especially practice of networks and
network leadership and how does
collaboration actually work among among
multi-stakeholders and um when I
discovered a couple years ago I
discovered Dows and it was like wow okay
here's some infrastructure and techn
techology that allows Global
peer-to-peer
collaboration and so uh I got obsessed
and I was all in on that um and and
that's really what what led me to start
coordinate and the three things I want
to share are are the factors that we saw
across all these different Global
networks all different contexts of
people trying to work together there
were three things right and they
are they are
uh the three things are
uh appreciation right really
appreciating what people are doing
information flow understanding what
we're working on and then finally reward
and so how are we rewarding people and
being reciprocal for what the the value
they put in and the value that they get
out so coordinate started inside of
urine Finance which is a decentralized
finance Dow and they were trying to
solve this problem of lots of
collaborators and lots of contributors
coming and doing great stuff
and how do we how do we allocate and
reward them and appreciate them for what
they're doing in a decentralized way
right so we don't have a grant committee
trying to decide who should get what um
as we developed coordinate inside year
other Dows started to get interested and
and also wanted to to use it and it
eventually spun out these are some of
the Dows that use us we now have about a
thousand organizations and 40,000
registered users um and recently also
exciting that companies totally outside
of web 3 crypto space uh there's a
company called iFood they do food
delivery in Brazil uh billion dollars in
revenue and 6,000 employees and they're
using coordinate as a sort of a core
pillar of their Employee Engagement
platform so how does coordinate work
it's organized by circles and
essentially you have one Circle that's
the big organization and then smaller
circles for projects or teams that are
populated from members of the large
organization
so you could have a one-off project like
putting on a conference or you could
have ongoing projects like you're
building a platform or a
protocol and there's uh different ways
to be added to these circles you can
either be added by an admin you can also
be vouched in by other members or you
can gate these with only people who have
a certain po app or token or nft so you
can start an organization and say only
people who have the network state nft
that we got earlier this morning are
allowed to
join right so there three things
information and
appreciation and reward this is
information so this is the activity feed
and basically users come in and they
input and share what they've been
working on so that other people that are
working in that same project can see can
have context on on what are you doing
what's happening how can we might
collaborate right um and then there's
the give Circle right so by default each
person has 100 give in the circle that
they can allocate to other people
according to the value that they've seen
them add to a project so as I'm working
with people and I see the awesome work
that they're doing and I want to
appreciate them for it I can allocate
give I can go and review and see all the
different contributions they've made I
can react to them and I can leave a note
right and this is really important I can
tell them hey here here's why I
appreciate what you're doing here's why
it's great um so overall we've had over
41 million give allocated so far uh
across the
system and appreciation right this is so
critical so these are just a few treats
that illustrate how important this
appreciation part is and this is
especially true when we're collaborating
online and collaborating asynchronously
and remotely it can feel isolating and
transactional so really taking that time
to appreciate and acknowledge the
contributions that people have made go a
really long a long way into making
people feel connected to a project we've
designed coordinate entirely around this
principle of appreciation and
acknowledgement because of these three
things it's the one that often times
gets overlooked or gets forgotten uh
there have been over 62,000 notes sent
across since we started and that's by
far my favorite me metric because it
really shows the kind of Good Vibes that
have been
flowing um so reward right compensation
so when used for compensation cordin
tape essentially distributes a budget
according to the number of give that
people have received right so if I get
20% of the total give I get 20% of the
total budget uh and you can use this um
on chain so for example you can have a
budget of some token in the circle and
when there it's complete it gets
distributed and people can come claim it
from our vaults or you can use any
number of methods to distribute uh
compensation and payment offchain as
well um so the other kind of reward that
we saw increasingly people get
interested in is not just compensation
for money but reputation right they want
to be able to to show the projects
they've been a part of and have a record
of their work so we created this which
is called coo and this takes your give
on chain so you actually have a
verifiable record of the projects you've
been working on and the the value that
you've added to them so it's one thing
to say oh yeah I was a contributor at
XYZ project it's a much different thing
to be able to say I was a contributor
and here's the value that I I added as
attested to by my peers that I worked
with so a big part of our road map is
actually expanding this Coole to
incorporate all sorts of different kind
of data and have really an onchain
reputational metric that will we hope
evolve into sort of like a web three
LinkedIn where you can find and vet
projects and collaborators uh we've had
28,000 of these minted so far and
encourage you all to uh mint your own as
well so this is a map that shows the
flow of give between a network so that
you have transparency and you can
understand who's giving to who and then
you can click in and start to understand
what are these people working on what
are they doing and we're also planning
to add lots of different data to this as
well so that you really have a robust
map and can understand your entire
project and what people are working on
and how they're collaborating
together
so what does this mean for a network
state right well if you're starting a
network State and or any kind of online
project you're going to be attracting
people who are really excited about your
idea and you're also going to be
attracting all sorts of the kind of
people that live out there online like
trolls and scammers and people like this
and so through cordinate you can
actually Grant access to your project
according to the people who the
community says are adding value right so
you can progressively Grant voting
rights or different kinds of powers in
privileges in your project according to
the the voice of the community and who
they're saying hey that person is doing
something awesome we should put more
resources there right it's really a way
to keep your borders of your project
open and without a gatekeeper but also
be able to quickly filter out a lot of
the noise that comes from any online
project right and so the the idea is
that really you can create hierarchies
of leadership that are based on
contribution and recognition from the
community and not just a sort of a rigid
pyramid structure right we see see we
say in an ideal Network we used to say
the leader is the one who knows what to
do next and so this is really a way to
tap into that collective intelligence
and let the community show who's adding
value and who can rise to the different
challenges that you face as your as your
project
evolves so whatever you're working on
whatever you're collaborating on
remember that the people you're working
with want to have information now I'll
get it they want information
appreciation and reward right and of
these things appreciation is often the
most important and most overlooked so
whatever you're working on make sure you
show a lot of love and thanks to the
people that you're collaborating
with